2007 on y revient parce que c'est
l'autre sujet d'actu que vous commentez
abondamment sur le site du figaro depuis
hier soir depuis les révélations alors
c'est pas franchement des révélations
parce que ça a été dit mais ça a été
remarqué par nos confrères du point dans
un premier temps les révélations donc de
la magistrate
eliane houlette sur la sphère fillon il
ya nul est donc été magistrate au
parquet national financiers cette
instance qui a été créée après laffaire
cahuzac et elle a eu à traiter la sphère
fillon et sur la forme du figaro au
winch boat vous poser cette question
mais qui était aux commandes du parquet
général qui est fait pression sur le pnf
sur le faire fillon aux ordres de qui
c'était eh bien oui je vote c'est
exactement la question que je me suis
posée en écoutant cette déclaration des
lianes houlette qui dénonce des
pressions n'ont pas on le disait pour
enterrer la faire mais au contraire pour
la faire accélérer le plus difficile
franchement c'est d'avoir d'arrêter de
virer en même temps la pression des
journalistes mais bon ça on peut s'en
dégage est bon je n'avais pas de contact
avec eux et je me disais plus les
journaux mais la présence et surtout la
l'impression du parquet général parce
que quand vous faites j'ai fait je
regardais les j'ai dit enfin sur une
fille dû regarder mais les demandes de
transmission rapide des éléments sur les
derniers actes d'investigation des
premiers éléments sur les actes de la
veille avant les demandes de précisions
les demandes de chronologie général tout
ça à deux jours d'intervalle à trois
jours
demande d'éléments sur des auditions
demande de notes des conseils avec les
mis-en-cause demande d'adp audition
demandes de précisions sur les
perquisitions en cours
demanda de précisions sur les
réquisitions supplétives bon donc oui on
ne peut que se poser des questions la
décision est rôle très étroit c'est un
contrôle très étroit et c'est une
pression très un contrôle très étroit
une pression très lourde mathieu
soutière est ce que ça vous a choqué
alors ça nous choque évidemment
d'imaginer qu'il puisse y avoir des
procès politique et des pressions
politiques mais je trouve que
précisément ce qui est décrit ici ne
relève pas de cela et je suis même
étonné en fait que la magistrate en
question et utilise l'expression de
lourdes pressions
j'ai regardé un peu les choses au
contraire il s'agit en réalité de
demandes d'informations alors dont il
est dit qu'elles étaient quotidiennes ou
quasi quotidiennes et précise mais que
sur une affaire comme celle ci en pleine
campagne présidentielle
des demandes d'informations soient
formulées sur un sujet aussi extravagant
est aussi sensible
ça me semble en fait on relevait
quasiment d'une bonne gouvernance
en fait il s'agit de demandes
d'information formulée par le parquet il
s'agit pas du tout de consignes imposées
par la chancellerie donc je ne vois pas
dans quelle mesure on peut parler de
pressions sur la justice
on était confronté à une situation
politique absolument inédites ou celui
qui était donné vainqueur de l'élection
présidentielle par les sondages alors
enfin deux fois les sondages se trompent
parfois et même souvent en tout état de
cause le favori de l'élection
présidentielle s'est retrouvée mise en
cause pour une affaire non pas comme
jacques chirac il ya quelques années et
financement illicite de parti politique
était de mettre d'enrichissement
personnel
voilà donc face à cette situation
inédite que le parquet est
quotidiennement suivi les choses que
paris en fait de bonne gouvernance une
bonne gouvernance je dit je vois
d'autres limites de la tête
moi je suis très surprise par ce
témoignage par ce système décrit est
vraie elle n'avait pas dû continuer elle
elle utilise elle même la juliette 2
le terme de pression d'immixion
insupportable mais dans ces cas là quand
on est à ce niveau-là on rend son
tablier
on dit on ne dit pas trois ans après oui
c'est vrai j'ai beaucoup souffert et et
ma démarche a été suivi de très près et
ça va causer un malaise par avance à lui
a causé un malaise dans tout casser
c'est ce qu'elle dit
mais de toute façon pour moi le parc
national financiers ne devraient pas
exister
je ne comprends pas cette juridiction
qui s'appelle financière me tiens est en
fait politique et non seulement qui est
positif mais qui choisit d'avec dossiers
politiques par exemple le parquet
national financiers ne s'est jamais
saisi de l'affairé bayrou des emplois
fictifs présumés du modem s'est jamais
saisit de la sphère ferrand je pourrais
multiplier les exemples qui prend les
affaires qui l'intéressent
ça ne me paraît pas du tout ça en
démocratie lucile votre point de vue sur
sur la question est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec mathieu est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est une bonne nouvelle sur
la gouvernance bias coûts partagés
plutôt le le point de vue de judith sur
l'opportunité l'inopportunité de
l'existence du parquet national
financier est peut-être le point de vue
de judith qui est un autre point de vue
duquel a exprimé qui est exprimé par
nicole cela veut dire que la magistrate
a fait passer sa carrière avant la
vérité pour avoir cédé à la pression
donc je pense qu'il faut rappeler
comment est organisé aussi la justice en
france c'est à dire que il ya d'une part
le parquet et d'autre part il ya les
magistrats du siège
est ce que ce que dit judith c'est
intéressant parce que on est en train de
créer des parcs et spécialisées
c'est-à-dire qu'elle parquet financier
et un parquet antiterroriste et à partir
de là il faut se rappeler que ya quand
même une hiérarchie entre le procureur
général est dit houle est c'est à dire
que moi je trouve ça tout à fait normal
qu'il ya une hiérarchie
on peut dire qu'il faudrait réorganiser
la justice écueil est que une
indépendance totale et que l'on supprime
le fait que les hiérarchies au sein du
parquet et ça c'est autre chose
la théorie llc habile enquête et je sais
pas si ce serait un bon choix parce que
je pense que si on avait une
organisation plus anglo-saxonne sa
supprimerait aussi l'autonomie du juge
d'instruction qui aujourd'hui totalement
autonome par rapport au parquet donc il
ya un sujet en tout cas soyons précis
sur le fait que quelque part est dit
houle est présente dans quelque chose
qui pourrait être perçu comme anormales
un problème peut-être tout simplement
effectivement qui est liée à
l'importance qu'elle est liée à
l'importance de la faire effectivement
comme l'a rappelé nature et quand même
on est en pleine présidentielle
et cette note du canard enchaîné c'était
franchement c'était impossible de ne pas
demander tous les jours d un compte
rendu et comme l'a d'ailleurs dit elle a
jamais eu pression de la chancellerie
j'avais l'impression ministériel ce qui
est bien le moins entre nous mais on a
le sentiment que c'était presque un
problème de personne à personne
en l'écoutant et effectivement on est
habitués sans doute à travailler selon
un rythme qui est plus plus lent mais là
c'est un contexte exceptionnel mais je
voulais quand même rappeler que l est
pas juges du siège et c'est normal que
procure un général lui demande des notes
de lui demande de rendre compte alors
qu'il ya un tel débat médiatique c'est
pas elle qui parle à la presse et c'est
tant mieux aussi
mais il faut pas non plus rester dans la
confusion là dessus après on peut parler
de l'organisation la justice en france
d'hier on voudrait qu'il n'est pas cette
hiérarchie au niveau du parquet ensuite
évidemment c'est ce que disait judith
elle a checké progrès table c'est
effectivement qu'il y ait des affaires
dont on ne se saisissent pas c'est à
dire qu'on ait le sentiment du 2
poids deux mesures ça c'est scandaleux
parce que je pense que ce mort problème
essentiel c'est que autour de la sphère
fillon on a eu ce sentiment aussi
parfois que c'était une manière de
décrédibiliser le candidat à la
présidentielle et de donc l' affaire en
justice étaient utilisés à des fins
électorales
je crois que c'est ça au fond qui relève
de ça et c'est parce qu a dit houle est
alors c'est par contre ce que disent les
internautes que je salue brice je vous
donne la parole dans un instant mais je
la donne à nos attentes je rappelle la
question d'abord que on vous pose sur
twitter êtes vous surpris par les
potentiels pression entre guillemets
exercer dans la sphère fillon alors vous
n'êtes pas très surpris dans vos
réponses
je cite jean notamment qui dit comme si
on ne le savait pas mais pourquoi en
parle t elle seulement maintenant expat
nous dit on aimerait que la justice soit
aussi diligente pour toutes les affaires
new wave l'ue estime qu'on joue avec les
mots ici chardon bleu lui pose la même
question que que j'en avais posé tout à
l'heure lucile pourquoi n'en parle tels
que maintenant et chardons lui nous dit
n'était pas claire mais quand même
donc ça y parle de france vous parlez de
françois fillon j'imagine chardon il
n'était pas clair mais quand même il y a
eu un certain acharnement contre lui
philippe lui pose une autre question
quid du cercle des donateurs qui ont
financé macron et christophe nous a posé
une bonne question qui a donné des
informations au canard enchaîné alors ça
effectivement on aimerait le savoir même
si on est protégée par un dispositif
auquel moi personnellement tant que
j'entretiens dur comme fer celui de la
confidentialité des sources
et vous brice quel est votre état
d'esprit êtes vous êtes étonnés ou
est-ce que vous êtes choqués ou bien
vous trouvez tout ça normal je trouve
tout ça absolument normal il faut se
souvenir du contexte en février 2010 est
le parlement a voté une loi amnistiant
enfin étendant la prescription et ne pas
vous affaire vieille de plus de 12 ans
autrement dit si la cie le la la
procureur du parquet national financier
n'avait pas engagé une procédure contre
françois fillon
les faits qui lui sont reprochés à
savoir je rappelle tout de même une
somme de 600 13000 euros d'après fillion
et sa femme humaine elle-même en tant
qu'assistante parlementaire entre
guillemets du candide de françois fillon
et son substitut de son suppléant marc
joulaud cette affaire n'aurait pas pu
éclater il n'aurait pu y avoir aucune
sanction pénale
ça aurait été vraiment de lamentables
donc il fallait aller vite
encore une fois ce petit et léana
houlette ce n'est nullement qu'elle a
subi des pressions pour ouvrir une
enquête
mais une enquête judiciaire mais pour
avoir des informations au quotidien
encore une fois je suis d'accord pour
entendre que le procureur national a
tout à fait le droit de demander des
informations sur une procédure en cours
au procureur national finance du parquet
national financiers c'est parfaitement
normal
je rappelle qu'il ya dans la même
interview qui vient de sortir
eliane houlette dit mot pour mot aucun
des gardes des sceaux ou leurs
collaborateurs immédiats ne m'ont
interrogé ou montrent ainsi qu'ils ne
montent ainsi d agir ou à ne pas agir
dans des dossiers particuliers donc il
faut il et il est scandaleux d'essayer
de faire croire que le parc national
demandant des informations un de ses
amis de ses subordonnés sur une affaire
en cours
le faire quoi qu'il s'agissait d' qui
ont politique exercée par le mystère de
l'est et le garde des sceaux de l'époque
en ce n'est pas le tas il s'agit
simplement d'empêcher qu'une affaire
soit rapidement enterrées et là encore
eliane houle a été très claire elle dit
qu'elle a été convoqué au parquet
général pour ouvrir une information
judiciaire elle a répondu ce sera quand
je l'aurai décidé
et quand j'aurai des éléments pour le
faire elle a effectivement attendu
d'avoir les éléments en question est là
ouvrir la formation en question le 24
février 2010 est quant à elle estimée
cela nécessaire qu'elle a agi en
conscience sans pression et il est très
maladroit politiquement d'essayer de
faire croire qu'il s'agissait d'une
opération politique pour déstabiliser le
candidat fillon comme on essaie de nous
faire croire
n'oublions pas que le programme du
candidat fillon prévoyait cinq cent
mille
tu crestian de fonctionnaire quand on
voit ce qui s'est passé dans les rues
avec les gilet jaune pour beaucoup moins
que ça on imagine assez bien ce qui se
serait produit c'est françois fillon
avec la fion charbon on nous dit fillon
et et corruptible c'est dommage certains
le savent et pas nous philippe estime
lui nous dit qu'il connaît des députés
qui ont longtemps employé leurs épouses
ils n'ont jamais été inquiétés pourtant
c'était la coutume on vous poser la
question sur twitter êtes vous surpris
par les potentiels pression entre
guillemets exercer dans la sphère fillon
est à croire que vous êtes désabusé
puisque vous nous répondez non à 4 près
de 82%
un peu plus de 80% très exactement
merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à ces
questions merci d'avoir des battues
âprement sur le sur le chat je salue
encore christian léon qui viennent nous
rejoindre pour la fin de cette émission
auditeurs internautes fidèles de points
de vue et ben je donne raison
je donne rendez-vous à christian les
ondes comme à chardon comme thucydide et
et où à jean-paul ou et nicole babineau
bien entendu et vous tous qui nous
avaient regardé demain à la même heure
même endroit judith brice lucile mathieu
merci beaucoup d'avoir contribué par vos
interventions à ce débat et vos
éclairages bien sûr à retrouver en
replay dans les articles du figaro sur
le site est également sur le portail
le nouveau portail figaro live je vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine demain
vous rendez vous ici même avec guillaume
roquette a très vite sur figaro live